- Dude, I'm on some adult shit,
you're on some hot mess shit.
- Did you call me a hot mess?
- What did you call me, a hot mess?
How dare you call me a hot mess,
I have never once.
- Welcome to Debatable, the
show where we subject ourselves
to stupid trival arguments,
so you don't have to.
Morning sex versus night sex.
On one hand, it's like,
"Woah, I haven't even had
my blueberry waffles yet,
"and this is happening?"
On the other hand, the moon is up,
the day has drawn to a close,
and you're finishin' up
the day on a high note,
if you know what I'm sayin'.
You know what I'm sayin'.
Are we gonna reach a resolution?
Probably not, but let's dig in anyway.
Morning sex versus night
sex, it's debatable.
(presidential music)
- Rise and grind.
- Bedtime booty.
(dramatic music)
- Morning sex. It just makes sense.
That's the slogan that
I'm gonna give to it.
- It sets the tone for the
day in such a beautiful way.
That rhymed.
- Your alarm goes off,
and there's someone lying next to you,
and you wanna get your blood pumpin'.
- Nobody likes workin' out in the morning.
I'm doing Trump hands.
- Just roll over, shag,
get your heart rate up.
- I love that you said shag, I'm sorry.
- Your body needs certain
things in the morning
for you to mentally and physically feel...
(grunts)
- That's what Prozac is for.
- Pop-a-pill culture, that'll
fix all of our problems.
- Some people need it.
- I get that.
- If you're having sex at night,
there's a lot of expectations afterwards.
Do I stay the night?
Does this person stay the night?
In the morning, no questions asked.
We gotta go!
- After I have sex,
I am like a little Energizer Bunny.
I'll do the dishes, I'll feed the cats.
- Have an orgasm in the morning,
how's your mood around 11:00?
How's that 2:00 feeling?
- I got poop breath, I look like shit.
No one looks flawless in the morning,
oh you look flawless.
- Not true.
- Oh, but my breath. Oh, but this.
Just go to the bathroom, take care of it,
do whatcha gotta do.
We're in the kitchen, maybe
cut up some cheese, crackers,
you know what I mean?
- You want cheese and crackers
for breakfast and then you wanna fuck?
- Appetizer, we're
talkin' appetizer foods.
- I'm not gonna wake up in the morning
and throw your ass from
one side of the wall
to the other side of the wall.
- I don't think Eli's
had sex before. (laughs)
- (laughs) I'm just sayin'.
- What is the point of
waking up, taking a shower,
eating your breakfast?
- No, listen man, all I'm sayin' is
get the act done, and then,
"Wow, I just had sex and
I'm having bacon and eggs."
Hello, paradise?
My eggs have chives on
'em and it tastes great.
- Okay, well, no one is that fancy,
and you fuckin' know it.
- Chives cost a dollar.
- Also, when you're straight,
it's usually ready for you in the morning.
- You're startin' pretty primed,
not to get vulgar.
- Oh, my pee-pee's hard,
so that makes it right.
- You know, it's just
like... (tongue click)
- I'm vomiting right now.
- You and your spouse are gonna have
a beautiful day together.
Every moment of the day
afterwards is gonna be
that much better.
- Oh, so you can only have
a connection if you have sex, got it.
- See this is the fake news.
It ain't workin', we're sick of it.
This is 2017, and this ain't
2015 Debatable anymore,
where you can just scream
and get in the thumbnail.
- Honestly, it's just the mood.
So it's dark out, you're
with your significant other.
- We got the drinks flowin',
already shaved the hoo-hah down there,
I am prepped for this moment.
- Cuddlin' in bed, and watchin' a movie.
- Let's watch Harry Potter,
drink a couple glasses of wine.
You usually don't finish the movie.
Usually you watch a movie, I'm like,
"What was that about?"
I don't know, but I know
what you look like naked.
- If I'm spending the night with you,
we better fuck before
nine a.m.
- (laughs) A.m.
- A.m.
- You're out drinking,
and then you come home and
you're feelin' sloshy and weird.
- Sounds like someone
has a drinking problem.
- Kelsey.
- You're not makin' love with somebody
three Leinenkugel's deep,
it's not happening.
I'm sorry, that is raw, gross, just rude.
- You can fuck, it
feels like it's endless.
- What if you like a
good snuggle at night?
- After we fuck, yeah.
- And it could go for a while.
We can start hittin' it at eight,
and we can hit it all
the way to eight a.m.
'Cause guess what, Daddy
gotta work at nine.
- You've never heard of someone having
a morning booty call.
"Hey, you up yet?"
- Dude, I'm on some adult shit,
you're on some hot mess shit.
- Did you call me a hot mess?
- What did you call me, a hot mess?
How dare you call me a hot mess,
I've never once.
- You know it's about to go down,
you know we're gonna do it on the couch,
we're gonna do it in the
kitchen next to the tomatoes.
- Again, I don't think Eli's
ever had sex before. (laughs)
- (laughs) Look, I'm just sayin.
- At night, there is
nothing more relaxing.
It's like exercise,
you can burn calories while you doin' it,
and then just drift--
- Any doctor will tell you
that you shouldn't exercise before bed.
That's day one stuff.
- That's very not day one.
- That's what you gotta resort to.
- When has Muhammad Ali
fought in the morning?
He trained in the morning, perhaps.
Talk about masturbation,
at the very least.
- Is that training?
- What?
- What do you mean?
- Masturbation?
- Masturbation.
- Yeah, masturbation can be training.
(presidential music)
- To sum it all up,
morning sex is the best.
It's valuable intimacy
with another person.
You know, plus you start
off with a boner already.
- Night sex is better,
and there is no better
feeling in the world
than having an orgasm and
falling straight to sleep.
If you fuck in the morning,
you end up like this.
- Well-rounded adult, ready
to go to a farmer's market?
Oh boy. Kids, look out.
- As the sun is rising, you are coming,
and you feel like one with the universe.
- Right. And I'm like, when
the sun is going down, so am I.
(laughs)
- [Man With Glasses] You guys are cute,
you guys are cute trying
to just mock my style.
I would love to meet my match one day
in the Debatable pit.
I wanna meet my match right here.
(swoosh and creak)